hey guys it's Justine and today I've got
something very exciting I know I know
every time I start a video out I say
it's gonna be exciting because usually
it is I'm not gonna make a video about
something not exciting today we were
checking out the brand new hot pink iPod
touch the announcement of this kind of
took everybody by surprise I feel like
like it was definitely something that we
weren't expecting god it came out of
nowhere you guys started tweeting me
non-stop because of this it comes in
this beautiful hot pink color another
thing that's kind of crazy it's a few
days before this was announced I tweeted
about wanting a pink iPhone and then a
few days before that I had made a video
talking about how badly I wanted to
think I phone and then concept creator
made this for me this beautiful render
of what an iPhone 11 are it potentially
looked like and then this is announced
which I was excited about but also a
little bit upset because if they made a
pink iPod that means they probably
aren't gonna make a pink iPhone or it
could mean they are gonna make a pink
eye phone because they already have two
pink here the color is here this is
exactly the color that I had one did I
tweeted it because I was super excited
about the color and everyone kept saying
just seen there was already a pink iPod
but I don't think that this is pink they
may have called it pink but this is more
of like a salmon ish type color so yes
well they have had a pink iPod
previously it is like a hot pink I also
made this little chart here so this was
kind of a chart of showing all of the
pink iPods in iPod history I was kind of
crazy because I didn't actually realize
that there were so many anyway let's
open I've been talking too much it is
that the only thing that I needed to
take off I haven't had an iPod and so
long it's beautiful oh wow it's so small
look how tight it is like a baby - pink
colors absolutely this is exactly the
color that I wanted it's almost like
that
like went into my brain and made this
color from my mind this is exactly the
color that I love let's see what else is
in here
paperwork lovely lightning cable great
and
Samir Potts now for the moment I've been
waiting for
and you probably happen to have you come
out of there you're in there aren't you
look at this okay we gotta peel the
sticker off
[Music]
it's so small compared to the iPhone
tennis max plus I have his battery
charger on it so this is so massive like
it's crazy
let's turn on this is great setup new
iPod touch unlocking to continue alright
so one of the things that a lot of
people were saying is who's gonna buy an
iPod Touch and to you I'm saying well
obviously maybe you aren't
this definitely isn't something that I
would need because I have an iPhone but
for children or people who may have an
Android device or a phone that is not an
iPhone this is basically all you would
need to listen to music
it also has iMessage as also has the
a-10 fusion chip so it is incredibly
fast so you can do augmented reality you
can play games so essentially this is a
very tiny small little phone without the
data this comes in three different
storage capacities there is the 32 V 128
and a 256 and there are five different
colors you have this beautiful pink but
we also have Space Gray white gold blue
and the product bread so if the pink
isn't something that you're into you've
got some other color options as far as
price goes these start at 199 which is
kind of crazy because that is one of the
least expensive iOS devices most people
may not want to buy the latest the
greatest feld but if you just want to
listen to music watch content have
something to play games on then this is
basically all you would need I actually
think it's pretty smart that they really
cease because the price point is so low
that just means that more people can
have iOS devices in their hands which
means they
more subscriptions to Apple music to the
Apple arcade to be new Apple premium TV
service Apple news to everything Apple I
also think this could potentially be
someone's first Apple device especially
the under kids or people that have
families you don't want to be giving
your kids your iPhone so you would
probably want to give them something
that is a little bit less expensive but
still be able to do pretty much
everything you can still send messages
you can do FaceTime calls you can
actually do group FaceTime calls on this
as well I don't use the group FaceTime a
few times but I hope you guys remember
judge nor did this incredible video of a
group FaceTime there was like 28 of us
on there maybe even more I think this is
the first time anybody actually tested
this yeah working as well as it is right
I think yeah everybody's face when they
come to the floor friends very I thought
a lot of people on Twitter asking what
this little black section was on the
iPod touch I was actually wondering the
same thing myself so I googled it and it
turns out this is your Wi-Fi antenna I
also saw some threads of people talking
about thing you can put a case on this
you can cover the antenna and it doesn't
affect the signal strength so that's the
new iPod touch I would love to know what
you guys think of this - you have an
iPod which iPods have you had in the
past do you guys want to check out that
iPod history picture that I talked about
earlier of the link to my tweet in the
description so you can go check that out
but I'd love to know what you guys think
of this do you think it's a good idea do
you think it's
not a good idea would you get one I
think it's great I mean it really is an
iPhone without the data plane Wi-Fi is
everywhere so really if you needed to
you could get by by using just this and
no bone maybe I should do a video about
that 24 hour challenge using the iPod
Touch only as my communication device
that's actually so easy that's not even
a challenge I would have all of my email
I could still make phone calls I can
text I don't think that's a fair
challenge okay this is a front-facing
test of the iPod Touch
[Music]
there might be some crime this is it
front-facing test I'm walking around
it's pretty good
this is back facing camera that's me
that is you it's you it's me it's me
it's you I don't have anything else to
say but I do have my air pods and so
does this make me cool oh shoot I need
it got my name on it oh cool I forgot to
do that when I purchase mine I'll see
you guys in my next video thank you so
much for watching and I will see you at
WWDC again if you're not subscribed make
sure you subscribe hit the bell also
follow me on Twitter and Instagram as
iJustine bye oh I can't wait let me do a
DC is gonna be so fun maybe I'll bring
my pink iPod and I will don't know what
I'm gonna do with it I've just to hold
and carry it around like this this is
gonna be me at witc oh it's beautiful I
love it I love it it's beautiful it's
beautiful
you
[Music]